i'm marine biologist imani weber schultz
i study sharks today i'll be answering
your questions from twitter this is
shark support
[Music]
at stop finning de asks what causes
sharks to attack humans this is a really
complicated question one of the biggest
reasons is we are putting ourselves into
their environment now when it comes to
people right we can put our hands all
over the place to observe our
environment sharks don't have that and a
lot of times what ends up happening is
they might hit their nose on something
to try and figure out what it is they
also take what we call exploratory bites
what it appears is that they're actually
just trying to figure out what we are at
kanto azul mc asks what are shark bones
made of sharks don't actually have any
bones they are made entirely of
cartilage at solarglide asks how many
species of sharks are there this is a
really fun question because we actually
just recently passed the 500 species
mark which is insane so there's many
ways to separate a shark from your
standard bony fish one of them is their
gill slits most sharks have five gill
slits but they can actually have up to
seven gill slits your standard fish
usually only has one another thing that
separates them is they have a very fatty
liver which would be this orange bit
here in this anatomical model and the
liver is huge and the reason for that is
sharks lack a swim bladder so a bony
fish has a swim bladder and that's what
helps them maintain their buoyancy
sharks don't have this they have a liver
and it's super oily and that's what
allows them to maintain their buoyancy
in water at great thunder asks is
climate change to blame for a string of
shark attacks across america when you
think about climate change one of the
things that we really think about is
warming oceans one of the things that
we're finding is sharks and fish in
general are actually moving northwards
where the water stays cooler for longer
months but it's not so great for all the
people who are going in the water in new
jersey in new york in the beaches you're
getting into their natural habitat and
there's a couple of different
interactions that are going on their
prey items seem to be moving more
inshore or into shallower waters we're
also in the shallower waters then there
might be an increased chance of
experiencing a shark bite but in reality
your chances of being bitten by a shark
is about 1 in 3.7 million you are more
likely to die from a vending machine
falling on you from a coconut falling on
your head or even just a dog in the
street at vincent w yedlin asks
hammerhead sharks have always fascinated
me why do they look like this what is
the purpose of having a shovel head and
eye position like that and do they
function better than a normal shark
hammerheads are very fascinating we all
know that they look completely different
and one of the distinctive features of
them is this hammer part which is
actually called a cephalofoil hammerhead
sharks are the most recently diverged
species of shark meaning that they're
the most recently evolved and we
actually don't really know why they
evolved this hammer but we can kind of
pick apart maybe some reasons why on the
bottom by their mouth this whole thing
is lined with ampullive lorenzini which
allows them to detect electrical
currents so as they're swimming along
and they eat rays and these rays have a
tendency to be kind of buried into the
dirt this is constantly feeling for
electrical pulses so any sort of muscle
movement for example and they can really
pinpoint where that ray might be without
actually having to see them because of
this ability to see through this
electricity and their eyes are all the
way on the outside some of our guesses
is hammer heads of a much wider range of
vision they can see almost 360 degrees
around their body which really separates
them from other species of shark at i am
jane cruz asks what's the most dangerous
type of shark there are three that can
we consider to be dangerous or more
aggressive and those are the great white
shark the tiger shark and the bull shark
now the bull shark is very famous
because it can actually travel up rivers
into fresher water and is the only
species of shark to go in between sea
water and salt water so if we're hanging
out in a river and there's that shark
one it's murky they can't really see
anything so they have a tendency to be a
lot more curious and therefore that
appears to be a lot more aggressive at
bill and durden asks how do sharks have
so many teeth they don't even drink milk
wtf so if you think of people we only
have two sets of teeth that come in we
have our baby teeth we lose them and
then we have our adult teeth if you look
at the inside of a shark jaw they
actually have teeth that line the upper
and lower jaw as these teeth fall out
new teeth will replace and become active
teeth and form to help them eat and
while that's happening when space is
created a new tooth will start being
formed so they essentially end up with
these layers and layers of layers or
conveyor belt as many people say of
teeth that are perfectly formed and
ready to move in at ingnong 1115 asks
shark after dark what's the most unique
thing about tiger sharks what separates
them from other sharks aside from their
markings tiger sharks also are known to
eat almost anything people have found
license plates tires and even lawn
chairs in their stomach and one of the
things that is super odd about them is
that they consistently throw their
stomach up their stomach fully comes out
of their mouth to just eject whatever is
in their stomach that they can't eat and
this stems from the fact that their
normal prey item is turtles and they
can't really eat that turtle shell the
real answery one asks what does the skin
of a shark feel like shark skin feels
two different ways so if you move your
hand from the head all the way down to
the tail they feel smooth but if you
move your hand from the tail to the head
it's quite rough and there's a lot of
resistance and this is because of their
scales so shark scales are called dermal
denticles if this very blown up large
version of a scale was placed on this
shirt it would sit like this and it
would layer and layer and layer and this
lower part here is the base of it this
would actually be embedded below the
surface of the shark so as they're
swimming water is almost perfectly
moving over their body giving them
less resistance than what we would
experience and actually helping them be
as quiet as they are at reward hana asks
how sharks can detect blood at one part
per 25 million parts of water one of the
really big myths about sharks is that
they can smell a drop of blood from a
mile away a particle of blood actually
has to travel through all of that water
and end up in their nose they can't just
say oh this is the entire stream it
passed they have to keep having a stream
of particles that brings them to you
they can swim around you and have no
idea that your blood is in the water at
haley jacoby asks so if sharks have to
move to be able to breathe how do they
sleep i want to address the first part
of this question which is that sharks
don't actually have to always move to
breathe there's kind of two separate
breathing mechanisms that sharks employ
the first is called obligate ram
ventilating and that is where a shark
absolutely has to move they just hang
with their mouth open essentially and
the water will just flow out over their
gills passively think great white sharks
hammerheads bull sharks they're
constantly swimming because they have to
be but then we have a category known as
bugle pumpers think nurse sharks sitting
on the sea floor or any kind of shark
that's just hanging out around the
bottom they actually have special cheek
muscles that allow them to suck water in
and flush it out over their gills so
they do not have to be moving to breathe
when it comes to sleep the sharks that
we know the most about their resting
time is bugle pumpers some sharks will
be observed in this resting period with
their eyes open which is really
fascinating so this whole sleep in
sharks is something that we're still
researching very heavily at miss kayla
joy asks how do you track a shark you
actually have to catch them first once
we've caught the shark we can then do a
work up on it and add a tag into it and
there's a couple of different ways this
will tag sharks the first one is just a
satellite tag this is probably what most
people would expect of a tag it's a
decently sized package that goes right
onto the back of that top dorsal fin and
it actually pings up to satellites the
next is an acoustic tag now this is
typically implanted into the body of the
shark another one is a great way for
normal people and non-scientists to
really get in to shark research and that
is just a standard id tag this
essentially goes into the dorsal fin of
the shark you have a little device that
lets you do this you stick it into the
dorsal fin so on this tag there's a
couple of different pieces of
information the first is just a standard
id number we would read this number off
and then we could go into our excel
sheet and say oh we caught the shark two
weeks ago and it was in this place
there's a lot of different reasons that
we tag sharks but the overarching
question is what are they doing and
where are they going mostly because we
just want to know in what areas of the
world they're living in what are they
eating where are their nurseries so
there's all these overarching layers of
why tracking is important at rogue
sharks asks what are baby sharks called
they're called puffs and it's amazing
out lousy scouty asks siri do sharks lay
eggs this is a really interesting
question sharks actually have three ways
of reproducing the first is they'll just
lay eggs you can swim around the
seafloor and you'll see things like a
mermaid purse which is basically just an
egg case that sits on the seafloor and
develops the shark and when they're
ready they kind of punch out of that egg
and they're ready to go they get the
term purse because they actually kind of
look like a purse depending on the egg
that you're looking at the second is
they have eggs inside the mom and in
each egg there is one shark and that
shark is slowly developing over time
with a yolk sac attached to it and once
they hatch inside the mom from their egg
the mom will then give birth to the live
pups which is really fascinating and the
last one is just live birth so similar
to how we do they just give birth to
live pups and a really interesting
example of this is sand tiger sharks
sand tiger sharks will have a whole
bunch of eggs inside their body some
shark shortcakes will become fertilized
and as they begin to grow they actually
start eating their siblings while
they're in the womb so there's kind of
this crazy hunger games thing going on
inside and instead of giving birth to a
whole bunch of different pups all at
once and hoping that they'll be able to
live they actually give birth to just
two pups that are already very strong
and already know how to behave like a
shark at dive magazine asks why do
sharks glow in the dark some sharks have
this really cool ability to bioluminesce
which is producing light from organs
within their body one in the case of the
cookie cutter shark is to actually
attract larger prey items that may want
to eat them so they can whip around and
take that nice cookie cutter
bite out of them another is counter
shading sharks that can bioluminesce in
specific ways produce some light to
blend in with any light that a predator
below them might see above they're able
to avoid being eaten because they have
this bioluminescent ability at blakeney
cfa asks shark week trivia what is the
fastest shark the fastest shark is the
short fin mako and it can swim up to 45
miles per hour which is very different
from most of the other species that we
know of at hurt olympics asks what are
sharks afraid of those mothers ain't god
whether or not sharks actually
experience the emotion of fear or being
afraid of something is hard to say when
you're in the water with sharks a lot of
them have a tendency to be skittish some
of them are really curious you can think
sharks that people dive with nurse
sharks oceanic white tips but many
sharks actually just avoid people
altogether because we're not a natural
item in their habitat and they're
generally pretty cautious so if they're
not really going to come up to you and
be curious about you they'd rather just
steer clear of something that they're
not sure what it is at kalilo asks for
how long do greenland sharks live
grayling sharks inhabit very cold water
and they have a very slow metabolism
based on our research we estimate that
they live 250 to 500 years old at team
finfrey tweets question what's your
favorite shark go
fin free my favorite shark is the bonnet
head this is the smallest species in the
hammerhead family so it is actually
related to the great hammerhead and they
also have this really insane ability dr
samantha lee discovered that this is
actually the only species of shark that
is omnivorous meaning that they can
actually digest grass which is not a
thing that we'd expect from sharks we
generally think of them as being
carnivorous only at hunter jordan asks
does the megalodon really exist it did
exist it's extinct now megalodon was a
really big shark and they also have
these really big teeth so this is a
replica a lot of people have actual
megalodon teeth that they find when they
go diving and actually lets us figure
out what the size of the animal might
have been they lived in kind of the
warmer ocean regions and our oceans have
a tendency to be pretty cold now when
you consider all this together there's
really not any territory in the ocean
that the megalodon could thrive in
there's no nursery grounds that we know
of and their prey items kind of just
disappeared and changed to make it
harder for them to actually be able to
eat at darker desai asks how to take
care of sharks google search in
captivity usually what aquarists will do
is make sure that that temperature of
the water is the optimal temperature for
them to live in and they'll make sure
that they're feeding them as often as
they need to sharks don't necessarily
make good pets and they're also not
always great in aquarium so there's not
a whole lot of great whites in aquariums
for example but you do see things like
sand tiger sharks whale sharks nurse
sharks which are sharks that are a lot
easier to take care of and aren't as
finicky in the environment that they
need to be in at nat geo asks how long
have sharks been swimming in the ocean
sharks have been around for around 450
million years at matt nj81 asks what is
the most endangered shark species now
it's really hard to pinpoint exactly
what species is the most endangered if
you find a shark that is critically
endangered that means that we are really
unsure of either if they might exist
we've only seen a couple of them a
really good example of this is the
ganges shark which was actually a river
shark that we haven't seen in a really
long time at mjgx asks jaws wasn't a
real shark was it just based on a real
story or something so jaws was not based
off of a true story the shark you see in
the film is a robotic shark and his name
was bruce but while they're hunting
around for bruce and bruce is supposedly
eating all these people they do pull up
a shark that they put up on a crane and
this is a tiger shark you know that this
shark is in fact real because it has its
claspers attached claspers are the male
sexual organ on sharks that are just
hanging off the back of the shark in all
their glory so next time you watch jaws
be on a look out for that at jeff
ellerton asks did sharks go through a
mass extinction 19 million years ago we
think that at some point something
changed that resulted in a mass
extinction of all these sharks and the
way that we know that is because in our
fossil record there's a sudden drop in
the amount of shark tentacles or teeth
from before the 19 million years to
after and that lets us know that there
was this big extinction we're not
entirely sure what it was but it seems
like the population's really dropped at
stackdeck 3 asks why do sharks migrate
to different places this is a really
good question and we're really still
trying to figure out a whole answer to
it some sharks have specific places that
they go to mate there are specific areas
called nurseries where young sharks will
live until they're big enough to kind of
venture out into the open ocean another
reason is to follow prey we as people
will fly to other places all around the
world just because we're curious about
traveling sharks kind of have a tendency
to also travel and we don't really know
why for some reasons but we do for
others at abi rupon asks how do sharks
see smell and hear so sharks have eyes
just like us so they do actually use
their vision to observe their
environment they do not have 20 20
vision neither do i as you can see to
aid with that they have all of their
other senses like hearing and smell and
the ability to sense pressure changes
and the ability to detect electricity to
create this whole overarching picture of
what their environment looks like in a
360 view you'll see all these spots all
over the bottom of their head and
sometimes even on the top and this is an
organ that essentially can detect
different electrical pulses so sharks
have a lot of different senses that
allow them to sample their environment
at a way higher level than we are able
to at mcm sharks xx asks how are hashtag
sharks important and why do they matter
in regards to our ocean we think of
sharks as being apex predators so
they're at the top of that food chain
and in an ecosystem there's constant
control going up and down if you think
of grass growing in a fish coming and
maybe eating that grass and then there's
a carnivore that eats that fish and then
there's a bigger carnivore that eats
that fish let's say we remove the fish
that eats the grass and the predator
that was eating that fish might not have
any prey to keep eating and if that fish
is gone then sharks don't have anything
to eat when sharks are removed from an
ecosystem there's kind of all this these
crazy environmental changes that can
happen and some of that ends up being
less control on things that are below
them at zixt asks sharks have eyelids do
sharks blink sharks don't blink in the
sense that we do they do have something
called a nictitating membrane which is
an eyelid that will fold over some
shark's eyes when a predator gets close
and it's just a protection mechanism at
eos green bay asks hashtag tuesday
trivia what is the largest species of
shark currently living in the ocean the
largest species of shark actually is the
whale shark which can get up to 18
meters people often will say that it
gets up to the length of a school bus
which is massive they actually eat
plankton so they don't eat meat in the
same way that we expect other sharks too
which is really fascinating so those are
all the questions for today i really
loved answering them and i hope that you
learned something new thanks for
watching shark support